students at Hofstra University are
demanding that the school tear down a
statue of Thomas Jefferson meanwhile a
northern California Public School
District is considering painting over a
mural of George Washington because a
working group deemed the painting quote
traumatizing to students and community
members we will analyze the end of
history then an alabama legislature
admits abortion is murder academics
normalized pedophilia and finally the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you ever noticed that President Trump
has this bizarre knack for predicting
things I'm not saying he's historically
very well versed or you know is the most
book-learnin man that's ever walked the
earth but he has this incredible knack
for predicting things and one of his
predictions just came true again in a
really distressing way we'll get to that
in a second but first hiring used to be
very hard multiple job sites stacks of
resumes a confusing review process today
hiring can be easy and you only have to
go to one place to get it done zip
recruiter dot-com / Knowles KO wles
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but they
don't just stop there it's not just
spaghetti at the wall that's not going
to get you very much with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective the four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
equality Canada through the site within
the first day right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address the zip recruiter
dot-com / Knowles KO wles that is zip
recruiter com / Knowles ko wles
bad hires can cost you a lot of time and
a lot of money and a lot of stress don't
do it make sure you get the most
qualified candidates today zip recruiter
com / Knolls zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire president Trump has this
incredible ability to predict things so
he did I the first time I noticed this
was in 2015 he announced that he was
running for president on June 16th 2015
you remember he comes down Trump Tower
he gives this long speech about how
illegal aliens are criminals they're
threatening the country we need to build
a wall we need to block the illegals
from coming into the country and he was
pilloried for this they said illegal
aliens don't commit crime they stop it
how dare you it's awful it's made-up
it's fiction and then what happened two
weeks later we had one of the most
high-profile murders in recent memory
and it was an illegal alien who killed
Katie Steinle an American citizen and I
thought does this guy just does he just
say things and then reality decides to
comport with whatever he's saying so
this all said this happened first of all
with his election he predicted when he
did that that roast of Donald Trump on
Comedy Central and everyone thought he
was a joke running for president
2011-2012 he said look I'm not sure if
I'm gonna run but if I do I'm gonna do a
lot better than everyone thinks I'm
gonna do everybody laughed at him we
were told by all these Nobel
prize-winning economists that the
economy would crash if he were elected
he said it would boom what happened it
boomed this happened again and this is
an even more consequential prediction
than any of those you remember during
that Charlottesville incident President
Trump made a very precise prediction
about what would happen if we start
knocking down Confederate statues was a
slave owner was George Washington a
slave owner so will George Washington
now lose his status are we going to take
down excuse me are we going to take down
are we going to take down statues to
George why how about Thomas Jefferson
what do you think of Thomas Jefferson
you like him okay good are we going to
take down the statue because he was a
major slave owner now we gonna take down
his statue so you know what it's fine
you're changing history you're changing
culture are we gonna take down statues
of Washington and Jefferson people said
Oh what are you talking about we're only
taking down statues of Confederates
we're only taking down robert e lee he
is a bad guy jefferson well he had
problems but we're not don't worry we're
not gonna take him down
except now less than two years later
that's exactly what's happening right
now at Hofstra University last Friday a
group of students hosted an event titled
Jefferson has got to go these students
have previously already defaced this
Jefferson statue at Hofstra they wrote
decolonize on it
they were black lives matter on it that
wrote all this other stuff on it who are
the organizers of this event Hofstra
students plane
Parenthood for some reason couldn't tell
you why and then local community members
and there is a real irony here by the
way that Planned Parenthood is hosting
an event to take down a Jefferson statue
because it's not nice to black people
Thomas Jefferson in enslaved black
people that is true Planned Parenthood
kills black people slaughters them on
mass black women get abortions at more
than three times the rate of white women
more babies in New York City are aborted
than born and planned parenthood has the
temerity to go to an event and say we
need to tear down our history because
it's not nice to black people because
this man owned slaves you kill black
people in New York more black people
killed than born neither here nor there
the Hofstra College Democrats also want
the statue gone it's not just at Hofstra
students at GW University now want to
get rid of George Washington for those
of you who don't know GW University
stands for George Washington University
and they want to get rid of their
namesake in their mascot this is the
majority of students here there was a
vote that was conducted 54% of students
at GW want to get rid of George
Washington how about George Washington
High School in Northern California they
now want to paint over they want to get
rid of a mural that depicts George
Washington in the way they did it is so
insidious it's just that creeping
tyrannical leftism that that seems like
it's nice and orderly
so they mask all of their totally
destructive instincts with this sort of
orderliness of bureaucracy and meetings
they didn't just take a sledgehammer to
it no they formed a working group oh
it's a working group there's a committee
they're gonna committee's gonna meet and
then they're going to decide to take a
wrecking ball to a work of art and a
piece of history the working group
decided that a mural of George
Washington the founder and father of our
country at a high school called George
Washington High School quote traumatizes
students and community members
it doesn't just offend them it trauma
system this is what we have been seeing
increasingly for years now what I see at
these universities when I go and give
speeches there they are conflating
speech with violence so it's it's this
peak work of art this work of history is
not simply offensive it's not simply
unpleasant it's not simply unappreciated
no it is traumatizing which is to say it
is committing an act of violence that
has physical repercussions on students
and so if the school is going to protect
the students safety their physical
well-being then they have to paint over
the artwork very clever strategy because
what the school should say is we're not
going to erase art and history because
you don't like it because some mob is
demanding it because what what is
happening in reality a mob is demanding
that we burn books burn history burn
artwork burn paintings that's what the a
mob is doing that but the way the left
organizes it is they say it's not a mob
it's a working group and we're not
destroying art because it offends us
we're destroying art because it
traumatizes us it committed violence on
us so we now will commit violence on it
the district spokesman so the spokesman
for the administration of the school
district said quote at its conclusion
the group voted and the majority
recommended that the life of Washington
mural be archived and removed because
the mural does not represent the school
district's values then what values does
the school district hold because George
Washington the father of our country
created the greatest country in the
history of the world a country premise
Don the idea that all men are created
equal that were endowed by our creator
with certain unalienable rights among
them life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that that man and what that
man established and presided over and
fought for and won has led to the most
just most equitable most prosperous most
charitable country
in the history of the world ever at
anytime
certainly now by orders of magnitude if
the school district doesn't stand for
that what do they stand for what are
their principles they apparently oppose
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
they oppose charity they oppose justice
they oppose equality they oppose what
are they what do they stand for if we
were to give this school district the
benefit of the doubt it seems that they
just don't know anything about history
they don't know anything about George
Washington they don't know anything
about what George Washington stands for
but that indictment is just as bad
because they're a school district they
are supposed to educate students but
they don't know anything themselves they
don't know anything about history this
is a real threat to the country and this
threat has been building for a long time
and Donald Trump is not the only guy who
predicts things there was another
prediction made by George Orwell in 1984
through the character of Winston which
describes this time that we're living in
perfectly he writes every record has
been destroyed or falsified every book
has been rewritten every picture has
been repainted every statue and Street
building has been renamed every date has
been altered and that process is
continuing day by day and minute by
minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right that's what
happens what happens when you get rid of
history because you might say who cares
it's a statue Oh
cares it's a monument oh who cares it's
some dates of some battles and some
things that some guy wrote without
history there is only an endless present
in which the party is always right if
you're not going to be guided by history
you are going to be guided by something
or somebody and in the absence of
history in the absence of fact because
when we talk about history we're talking
about facts history and facts are the
same thing facts means something that's
done something that's true it the word
fact comes for
the verb to do so fact is something
that's done in history but when you get
rid of that what are you guided by
ideology and who wields ideology like a
weapon ideologues totalitarians
activists politicians the party is
always right totalitarians hate history
this is why all of the most famous
totalitarian regimes in history have
immediately erased their own history
Stalin did this Stalin actually took
people out of photographs after he
purged them after he liquidated them
after they became politically incorrect
to his party habit in China they had the
the Great Leap Forward the Cultural
Revolution right they got rid of all of
their history they tried to deny all of
their history and just innovate from the
very beginning create the whole world
anew a terrible idea they always want to
erase history why because history gives
us context history puts all of their
schemes in a historical context when aoc
this poor empty-headed legislator 29
year old bartender comes up and says hey
I've got a plan that will completely
upend the entire American economy and
political system that will cost 93
trillion dollars that will get rid of
most of your private property rights
that will get rid of your homes will get
rid of all of your political rights how
about that is that a good idea I'm
promising you the world everything it'll
be better it's gonna save the whole
planet if you don't know history you you
might actually find that compelling if
you do know history you'll say hmm every
time these exact ideas have ever been
tried they've led to widespread misery
famine murder slaughter poverty misery
but they want to get rid of history so
that we don't impede their schemes
history also gives us something to
cherish so these are these are two
totally opposite ideas when we look
about it had history I gave a speech at
Notre Dame about Christopher Columbus
and how Columbus was actually quite a
good guy
and these students who were protesting
they came up and they said how could you
say that Columbus is a good guy he's
terrible everything about him is awful
everything he ever did was awful
everything he led to was awful
and then I started recounting all of the
good things Columbus led to first whale
into our country he created the Latino
race he literally created a race of
people he spread Christianity throughout
the world he he gave us what we have
it's something to cherish some people
look on history and they cherish that
tradition that they have others look on
it and they despise it they hate it they
stand on the shoulders of giants they
think that they're flying and they spit
on the people who have led them to where
they are the issue basically boils down
to the same reason why we respect our
elders why should we respect history
it's the same reason we we respect our
elders first of all why do you respect
your elders should you I think these
days were taught not to respect our
elders we're taught to talk back to our
elders or to dismiss them or to despise
our elders coincidentally at the same
time we're taught to hate our history
despise our history you know those are
just our elders in a you know whole
higher order of magnitude they're just
our elders much further back why should
you respect your elders in part humility
because it's the classic whiny angsty
teenager I hate my parents my parents
are terrible they're so dumb and wrong
and awful I hate them but I'm really
great there's nothing wrong about me
right
no you impart respect your elders
because it shows you a little bit of
humility you are just as flawed as you
are convinced that they are in part it's
gratitude because no matter how flawed
your elders are you're here because of
them in the case of your parents
literally their love is the reason why
you exist and in the case of your elders
broadly you are here in this society in
the civilization because of their work
because of what they have done
also because to respect your elders is
to respect yourself we are not just
isolated atoms floating in the middle of
nowhere
we don't just pop into existence in the
middle of the air and fall down and say
okay I guess here I am all my cell
an island unto myself no we are part of
a tradition we come from somewhere we
come from a culture that culture forms
us as much as we form the culture the
culture forms us actually the culture
forms us much more than we form the
culture and so those those traditions
that we despise that we hate that we
disrespect to disrespect those things is
to disrespect ourselves because they
form us they make up our character we
are connected to the past but these days
we're taught to hate ourselves that's
what the whole culture tells us to do
Americans are the worst Americans are
awful especially don't get me started on
straight white men don't get me started
on straight white men who think that
they're men oh if you're one of those
guys you have to hate you have to
despise yourself you have to shut up
never open your mouth never express an
opinion just just sit there and feel
really bad about how awful you are but
it's not just straight white men who
think that their men everybody has to
check their privilege because you have
some sort of privilege that's all you
got to hate yourself now if you hate
yourself you're going to hate your past
because if we're so bad then surely
those awful people in the bad olden days
they're even worse aren't they if we
enlightened modern people are so bad
they were terrible we're taught that our
culture is hopelessly bigoted so
obviously anybody who lived even five
seconds ago is hopelessly bigoted but we
are now told that the opinion that
Barack Obama had on gay marriage for his
entire political career up until seven
years ago is an example of pure
malicious bigotry because he thought
that marriage is an institution between
men and women husbands and wives because
he thought that that opinion is
hopelessly bigoted that was the opinion
that everybody held as recently as seven
years ago but radicals hate history you
notice it speeds up so now we're
changing history much more quickly once
you start to get rid of robert e lee
it's not like you get rid of the robert
e lee's statues and then
sixty years later you start to get rid
of the Thomas Jefferson statues no once
you grant the premise then it doesn't
proceed gradually it proceeds
exponentially because that's the logic
if we're going to erase our history if
we're going to erase our art if anything
bad that ever happened in the past is
not just unfortunate but traumatizing
it's literally harming physically people
right now you've got to get rid of all
of it
you gotta get gotta you've got to get
rid of Barack Obama's speeches from 2011
when he talked about marriage can't have
those those are traumatizing you can't
have a statue of Barack Obama it's
traumatizing ultimately you're going to
get rid of even the recent past you're
gonna get rid of five minutes ago all
that's going to exist is the eternal
present in which the party is always
right history shows that those utopian
schemes are going to fail shows us that
men are not perfect they're never going
to be perfect shows us that the world is
complicated you can't spell it all out
in some doctrine in some manifesto so we
got to get rid of it and the party will
always be right but we're not just
killing off our past we are also killing
off our future and at least you got to
give him credit there's one state
legislator in Alabama guy named John
Rogers who is at least being honest
about why Democrats want to kill babies
it all be a woman's choice I'm not about
to be in the mail till a woman was doing
her body she has a right to make a
decision herself directly instead some
kids and unwanted so you killed now I
killed him later you dragged him in the
world on one I love this em--to
nega-chin so you killed now a killer
later
but the bottom line is that I think we
should me make this decision kill him
now
or kill him later I love this clip I
kind of like this guy if you can't see
him he's wearing this baby blue suit
he's got this really thick Alabama
accent and at least he's honest he's
wrong but he's honest he's admitting a
true premise which is that abortion is
killing a baby he's admitting them he's
saying now we're not just performing
some procedure we're not just removing
the pancreas or something we are going
in and killing a human being he is
admitting that a baby is a person he's
admitting that we're killing these
babies selfishly you say yeah we're
gonna have to kill him eventually aren't
we cuz they're gonna be bad they're
gonna be inconvenient for us they're
gonna commit crimes so we got to kill
them now you get rid of them we're gonna
save ourselves a whole lot of headache
now what he's wrong about is he's
assuming that unwanted babies are going
to become criminals and we're going to
have to kill them send them to the
electric chair this is wrong for a
number of reasons one there's no
evidence that baby's given up for
adoption or babies raised by single
parents or babies raised who are not
wanted or not loved in inevitably become
criminals in such awful criminals that
they receive capital punishment there's
no I mean that he's pulling that
completely out of thin air this is an
argument that the left tried to make for
awhile like that Freakonomics book I
said oh yes the reason crime rates have
declined is because roe v wade legalized
abortion and so we're killing all the
bad kids who were certainly going to
become criminals this has been roundly
debunked and people did no longer
seriously make that argument but it's a
it's a weak argument anyway so we first
of all it's not an argument to kill
babies before they've committed a crime
I mean I guess that's the premise he's
trying to make it's a weak argument
because in the United States we kill
very few criminals anyway so you're not
going to kill them later and it's a
highly immoral argument because if if
that's the argument if you are just
saying look unwanted unborn babies are
likely to commit crimes let's grant that
premise
therefore we should kill them then this
is obviously true of any demographic
group that is likely to commit crimes
young black men in certain geographic
areas are very likely to commit crimes
statistically more likely than other
demographic groups is this guy arguing
that we should kill them now because
they're likely to commit crimes
that's a heinous argument but that is
the logical conclusion of the argument
that he's making
and then he admits by the way that it's
not really about crime then he admits
it's not that's not really about we're
gonna have to kill them later what he
admits is I just don't want these babies
they're inconvenient here he is
it's hard to hear it's not that that
microphone was not as good there
what he's saying is the child could be
born [ __ ] the child could be born
half deformed therefore we've got to
kill him
so [ __ ] people have apparently no
right not to be murdered people who were
deformed maybe the kids missing a few
fingers kill him who wants a kid who
doesn't have a few fingers oh could you
imagine anything worse than not having a
couple of fingers kill him
that is the disregard for human life
that we're talking about and I really
like that he's making this argument
because he's allowing the the ethical
and moral argument to take place in a
way where we recognize the humanity of
the baby he's allowing us to say okay if
by your logic we need to kill people
before they commit crimes why shouldn't
we kill any adult demographic group
based on race based on sex based on age
why shouldn't we do oh because it's not
legitimate to kill people before they
commit a crime okay well but then his
argument is well the kids [ __ ] okay
so if we can kill people because they're
not smart enough where's the cutoff
maybe in 90 IQ 95 IQ we'd have to kill
off basically all of the US Congress Dan
Crenshaw probably could still live Dan
Crenshaw would be the last remaining
congressman everyone else would be gone
by that measure is that is that what
we're going to do deformed someone but
if someone's ugly someone's got a little
fat you know they've got some pock marks
on their face or something we'll kill
them right they're deformed nobody wants
a deformed person how ugly either human
dignity human worth comes from some
superficial characteristic like IQ or
how you look or how many fingers you've
got or how much your parent loves you or
how well you're gonna be raised or the
likelihood because of your circumstances
that you're gonna be in situations where
you might commit more crime either it's
from that or its intrinsic human beings
have intrinsic
value those are the two options that's
the logic of abortion speaking of little
children a bunch of academics now want
to normalize pedophilia we'll get to
that in a second we'll also get to the
mailbag but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube so if
you're on Facebook and YouTube go over
to daily wire.com ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me you
get the inter Clayman show you get the
men Shapiro show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag you get them at
wall show you get to ask questions
backstage you get the leftist here's
tumblr where is my left is tears tumblr
oh my gosh I don't have a leftist here's
tumblr on my desk right now if those
doors to the studio open up I likely
will drown this could be my last show
don't be like me go get your leftist
ears tumblr we'll be right back with a
lot more
all right we have reached the end of
society I guess it's all over we had a
good run we lasted for I don't know
probably like five or six thousand years
now it's over academics in Britain at a
conference hosted at Cambridge
University one of the oldest and best
universities in the world have now
reached the logical conclusion of the
sexual revolution the normalization of
pedophilia what they say is that
pedophilia is normal and natural quote
pedophilic interest is natural and
normal for human males at least a
sizable minority of normal males would
like to have sex with children
normal males are aroused by children
this has been building for a long time I
think I've been predicting this for
years I'll have as well and everyone
said oh you're crazy it'll never happen
no way they'll never tear down statues
of Washington no way they'll never
normalize pedophilia yes they are doing
that and it doesn't take a genius by the
way to predict these things all you have
to do is realize what the premises of
the left are and then use your mind to
follow them to the logical conclusions
so the premise of we need to tear down
history that we don't like or that we
find offensive or that was wrong or evil
leads necessarily to tearing down all of
history the premise that sex is just
some physical action and that any
desires that we have are not to be
shunned or shamed or repressed but are
to be explored and liberated because
there's no such thing as normal there is
no such thing as wrong there's no such
thing as sinful sexual behavior the
logical conclusion of that is the
normalization of sex with children and
that's what these these people are doing
so in 1981 there was a respected
publisher Batsford published a piece
called perspectives on pedophilia edited
by a sociologist named Brian Taylor and
what Brian Taylor did was challenged the
quote prejudice against sex with
children now there is a prejudice
against pedophilia that's true
I think it's a pretty good prejudice it
is true our society has this prejudgment
we say sex with children is bad I think
this is Exhibit A evidence number one
that some prejudices are a very good
thing then in 1991 a professor wrote on
his blog this was recently republished
on 2012 quote many adult pedophiles say
that boys actively seek out sex partners
childhood itself is not a biological
given but in historically produced
social object you see the language of
all of modern academics all of this
relativistic academic culture childhood
doesn't even really exist it's just a
social construction male and female they
don't really exist they're just social
constructions everything's everything
you know man and nothing's really itself
and nothing's categorically distinct him
[Applause]
you know and like we're all just part of
the universe man that's the logical
conclusion of that idea debates are now
being had at the American Psychological
Association over the DSM over the the
book of psychological disorders over
whether or not to include haemophilia as
a disorder it's I believe it is now not
included as a disorder Heba philia is a
sexual attraction to children 11 to 14
basically after they're little kids but
before they're their post-pubescent the
sexual revolution types have been saying
for a long time that pedophilia is
normal and natural maybe he's right in
the sense that it occurs with some
frequency
you know when the sexual revolution
left-wing types say oh yes any kind of
bizarre sexual behavior is normal it's
natural it's no big deal
then you have the right-wing types who
are saying pedophilia is abnormal it's
unnatural it's obviously it can't be any
of the things that the sexual revolution
types are saying that it is maybe both
views miss the point maybe this is the
actual point let's say that pedophilia
is natural let's say that people are
born this way this has been the argument
for all the sexual liberation movements
say we were born this way we were born
with certain desires therefore we have
to fulfill them I
I'm perfectly fine with the conclusion
that some people are born naturally with
a desire to have sex with children it's
still wrong but we're born this way
doesn't matter it's still wrong it's
wrong to do it's evil it's a wicked
desire that you have to repress all the
time well let's say let's say that it's
not just natural let's say that
pedophilia as these academics in Britain
say is natural and normal so it's very
easy to imagine at some point in the
future that these guys get their way and
pedophilia is taken out of the DSM it's
no longer considered just a disorder
it's a sexual orientation it's something
you're born with and let's say lots of
people accept this throughout Society it
becomes totally normalized it's still
wrong but 80% of people say it's okay
right 80 percent of people are wrong but
five percent of people are born with
this desire right the desire is still
wrong this is a really tricky issue for
the sexual revolution and I guess for
the left broadly which has embraced the
sexual revolution because pedophilia are
natural correct revulsion toward
pedophilia and pedophiles shows us that
so many premises of the sexual
revolution are not true the the idea
that exists now I mean this is I think
the chief moral maxim of our age which
is if it feels good do it that's not
sufficient that's not true that's not
right certain acts are wrong certain
ones are right so now the way that the
left has gotten around this in recent
years is they've made consent the most
important thing you can do anything you
want to anybody but you need consent you
can smack your sexual partner around
you'll punch him in the face you're
gonna put a cigarette out on his
forehead
whatever you that's okay as long as you
get consent and so children can't
consent okay can a fourteen-year-old
consent I feel that when I was 14 I
could consent to a lot of things I was
able to consent to go work I had working
papers at 14 I had a job how was I able
to work a job if I couldn't
sent in that case I was a slave was I
really a slave or teenagers who work at
fast-food places slaves no in some way
they're consenting consent is
insufficient this libertine liberal
totally liberal culture of saying well
whatever you want to do is you know it's
fine just do it as long as you have
consent that's insufficient some things
are intrinsically wrong no matter who's
born that way no matter what people
think no matter how we can bend the
definition of consent it's just wrong
but if this is wrong then what else is
wrong what else does the moral order say
about our behavior not even just our
sexual behavior all of our behavior
that's a difficult question and
ironically as we've gotten so much worse
so much less able to have moral
discourse we're seeing the horrifying
conclusions of that perhaps that will
wake people up and say gosh I've gone
down a terribly wrong road here on my
trip to progress I've gone down a
horrifically wrong road I've gone to the
this awful conclusion and a CS Lewis
points out when you realize you're going
down the wrong road the person who turns
around and starts going in the other
direction is the progressive he's the
he's the one who is actually pursuing
progress we gotta get to the mailbag
first question from Elissa not sweet
sweet little ELISA
but ELISA hello Michael why can't
government's just print more money why
do people say it brings down the value
of the dollar I've never been explain
this and everyone else seems just to
understand and so I've always been too
embarrassed to ask thanks Alysa well
you're looking at Venezuela right now I
assume to see why you can't print more
money here's why
money refers to value money is a symbol
of value and what is that value that
value is goods and services it's the
production of our economy so you've got
the money supply and you've got the at
the real output of our economy the goods
the services the products made the
things built the things done okay the
money has to match the output so let's
say your economies were
20 million dollars and that's the that's
the output that you're putting out and
then one day the government decides it
wants more money so it starts to double
the amount of money it's printing now
the government is printing 40 million
dollars but your real output is still
only twenty million dollars well you've
got double the money but the same amount
of goods and services so as people go to
buy those goods and services everybody
knows you're printing more money
eventually people figure out the secret
and so what happens is the prices of
those goods and services will double
gradually but eventually they will
double what that is called as inflation
you get inflation because you can't
trick everybody you can't make something
out of nothing to quote the great
philosopher Billy Preston nothing from
nothing leaves nothing so these
ridiculous tin-pot dictatorships like
venezuela in latin america think that
the way that they can make up for all of
their overspending they their economy
made a certain output and then they're
just spending and spending and borrowing
and bribing people and doing all of this
and eventually when that catches up to
them and they say the bill comes due
they just start printing more money it's
not gonna work nobody cares about the
paper they care about what the paper
represents and there's no such thing as
a free lunch
from Evan hey Michael if my memory
serves me correctly when you were
younger you were an atheist true I am
sort of in the same boat as you in that
I was an atheist and now believe in God
mainly due to you and the influence
you've had on me it's nice to hear what
drove you to believe in God and what
would you recommend to someone who is
trying to explore faith thank you so
much for me it started with the
arguments for God and it started with my
recognition that all the people around
me this was during college all the
people around me were smart and they
were all atheists but the smartest
people were not atheists the very
smartest people were Christians and
generally they were Catholics or on the
road to becoming Catholics or Eastern
Orthodox also liturgical traditional
with a profound body of work and
philosophy and it
obviously natural law and all of these
sorts of things so I noticed that that
piqued my interest then I started
reading CS Lewis or GK Chesterton
started reading the arguments for God
the ontological argument that Alvin
Plantinga formulates the I mean Alvin
Plantinga is the most recent of zillion
people who have formulated it it goes
back to seeing Anselm of Canterbury and
the two mystic arguments for God from
st. Thomas and it occurred to me
eventually that the arguments for God's
existence were much stronger than the
arguments against God's existence now
you'll notice what word has been missing
throughout all of this is faith for me
it was initially almost entirely
intellectual then the experience and
practice of faith happened after what I
would recommend I didn't really go to
church very much almost never in college
and for me the reason for that was that
I was raised in the very liberal post
vatican ii catholic church where it was
all these awful insipid hymns that were
like you know bad pop songs with
saccharine lyrics and it was all just
kind of a show it was just you know the
priests would say hey be a good person
you know hey I mean you don't have to
really do anything or think anything I
don't know if anything is really that
true but be a good person I'm only
slightly exaggerating and then you'd all
hug and that's okay and it was really
more of like a I don't know therapy
group then real worship the purpose of
the mass or the purpose of whatever
church you go to is not to make you feel
really good about yourself you were
there to worship God and and you're
actually doing something and in the
churches that recognized the real
presence of Christ in the communion you
were there to literally commune with
Christ you were really doing something
it really matters this is why I found an
old Mass a Latin Mass or at least a
manís with some lab and I thought oh
gosh this is really beautiful I didn't
realize there was all of this beauty
before so what I would recommend to you
is however you're gonna do it whatever
church you come from or tradition you
come from do it really do it read all
the stuff
convince yourself intellectually it
seems like you've already done that and
then do it and realize that you're doing
something you're not just playing around
in a sandbox you are really doing
something and something is really being
done to you by the Holy Spirit when you
realize it's all true that will
obviously inform your faith and
transform your life from George this
morning I heard on a local radio station
here in st. Louis that you will be
speaking at the State Capitol in
Jefferson City on May 9th can you supply
or can you elaborate rather on this or
supply website to find out the specifics
that's true I am I'm going to be
speaking in Jefferson City at the state
capitol in Missouri I was invited by a
state senator there because my speech at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
was interrupted and because I was
physically assaulted and because the
awful Chancellor of that University
Molly Agrawal then chose to condemn me
and praise the the hecklers who were
trying to shut down a free discourse on
campus so I was invited to go give a
speech there at the State Capitol we'll
get more information out soon I actually
don't have it all on me right now but it
promises to be a lively event so if
you're around sure would love you to
come out from Ceph hello michael
knowledge I was talking to a friend and
she said that when she gets married
the husband will have to change his last
name to hers what do you think about
husband's changing their last name to
their wives well if she's waiting to
find a man who's gonna change his last
name to hers this might not end up being
too much of a problem for her she might
not have to actually answer this
question ever should wait a very long
time I think this is a bad idea I have
one friend who did take his wife's last
name and he came up with some elaborate
explanation of this that was
philosophical and everything I think
really why he did it is because he had a
really long kind of clunky last name and
his wife had this really sleek last name
that was short and so I think maybe it
was a little a little self-interest
there as well what that accepts is an
inversion of the tradition so what you
are traditionally the man is considered
the head of the house
and what does that mean does that mean
he's like dragging his knuckles across
the floor and bellowing like some some
tyrant or something no but it does mean
that the man has a leadership role the
husband has a leadership role in the
household and one symbol of this is the
family the whole family taking the
husband's last name if you are going to
take your wife's last name what you are
saying is we are going to invert this
traditional order so the wife is going
to have the leadership role in the
household what does this mean does this
mean that she's going to be the primary
breadwinner does this mean that you are
going to be the man is primarily going
to be the keeper of the home and the
nurturer and the person who raises the
children and the person who is is
keeping the family together in a more
private way well the wife goes out and
is the public face of the family and is
spending much more of her time in public
okay that's the life you want to live
that's fine I think there is a reason
why throughout all of history certainly
in our civilization and in the vast
majority of other civilizations it has
been the other way around something
about our nature probably leads into
that something about our inclinations
probably explains that if you want to
upend that and do the opposite and see
if backwards day works for the rest of
your life go for it I mean be my guest
but you are you are fighting against the
tides of your culture and civilization
history and maybe they knew something
too you don't from David hello Michael
I'm currently in college studying
English teacher education I'm thinking
about changing to a Poli Sci major
program do you think this is a useful
major and what would you recommend
studying to get into politics thanks
David
I think it's a terrible major I think
it's completely useless I don't
recommend studying political science Ben
was a Poli Sci major and he says the
same thing political science is a highly
politicized ideological major it it now
rarely focuses on political philosophy
which is a very worthwhile thing to
study and instead focuses on you know
statistics and social science and things
they're a little soft or a little a
little less related to the traditional
live
if it depends if you want to go into
politics I recommend you study history
or English perhaps literature or I guess
philosophy if you're interested in
political philosophy and maybe if you
want to go into politics you should
study business I don't know it depends
if you want a liberal education or a
more practical education and if you
study business you can make a whole lot
of money and then you can buy your way
into some political seat and rise your
way up if you want if you want to be an
English teacher I guess you should study
English or English education it depends
what you want to do with it Poli Sci can
be useful in the sense that a lot of
Poli Sci majors end up going to law
school if you want to go to law school
to get into politics then that's fine
what I would really recommend though is
doing what you are good at doing what
you naturally gravitate toward and
knowing somehow some way that that might
apply to the rest of your life
I studied liberal arts I studied history
and Italian literature those are not
mechanical arts those are not practical
you don't get a job out of those but I
was very interested in them I think
they're very good for understanding the
West understanding our culture
understanding human nature they're
obviously good for politics which is
what I'm doing now they're obviously
good for an understanding of the culture
and where things are going so it does
apply in that way Poli Sci I don't I
don't think really does that you've got
to figure out what you want so often
people go into these schools and they
just pick some random major just cuz and
then they come to regret it years later
don't end up with that regret we're
right now in a crisis of the American
University the whole thing is collapsing
around us and you don't want to be the
one who spent a quarter million dollars
getting a degree that well you come to
find out is useless all right that's our
she oh so much more to get to but we
just don't have time man I'm sorry we
will be back on Monday have a good
weekend in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael an old show
I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today socialist Venezuela is
as I'm sure you noticed falling apart
before our eyes
but it's pretty disturbing when you
think about when you see what's
happening in Venezuela and you think
about that so many young people in this
country want that system in America but
here's the question none of these people
seem to be asking themselves and it's
you know if socialism is a good system
then why has it destroyed every country
that has tried it and if socialism is a
good system then why wouldn't you want
to live in any of the countries today
that are socialist so we'll talk about
that also a democratic state
representative in Alabama made the most
horrific and insane but also the most
honest argument for abortion that you'll
ever hear and we'll take a look at that
today as well over on the Matt Walsh
show